>>> IN OUR HEALTH LEAD, NEW
AS PEOPLE'S SMOKING HABITS ARE
CHANGING.
A NEW STUDY FUNDED BY THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF HEALTH
SHOWS THE USE OF MARIJUANA AND
HALLUCINOGENS BETWEEN YOUNG
PEOPLE BETWEEN 19 AND 30 ARE AT
ALL-TIME HIGHS.
THIS COMES AS FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER, MORE PEOPLE SAY THEY USED
WEED THAN TOBACCO CIGARETTES.
HARRY ENTEN WHO USUALLY KEEPS
HIS EYE ON POLITICS HAS BEEN
INHALING SOME DIFFERENT KINDS OF
NUMBERS TODAY.
WHAT DID YOU FIND?
>> OH, MY GOD.
IF I CAN GET THROUGH THIS
SEGMENT WITHOUT LAUGHING IT
WOULD BE A MIRACLE.
HAVE YOU SMOKED OR EVER TRIED
MARIJUANA?
16% OF AMERICANS SAY YES.
THAT IS AN ALL-TIME HIGH.
YOU KNOW, WE ALSO HAVE THIS EVER
TRIED MARIJUANA PART OF THE
SCREEN.
I WANT TO KNOW, BACK IN OCTOBER
OF 1969, JUST 4% OF AMERICANS
SAID THEY EVER TRIED MARIJUANA.
SO WE HAVE BEEN SEEING THIS
CONTINUOUS UP TREND.
YOU CAN SEE EVER TRIED NOW UP TO
48%.
NOW, WHAT'S REALLY INTERESTING
TO ME IS HAVE YOU SMOKED
CIGARETTES IN THE LAST WEEK?
THE TREND IS GOING IN THE EXACT
OPPOSITE DIRECTION, JAKE.
SO NOW, JUST 11% OF AMERICANS
SAY THEY HAVE IN FACT SMOKES
CIGARETTES IN THE LAST WEEK.
THAT'S AN ALL-TIME LOW.
GO BACK TO JULY OF '69.
LOOK AT THAT, NEARLY HALF THE
POPULATION AFF40%.
MARIJUANA SMOKING, RECORD HIGH.
SMOKING CIGARETTES, RECORD LOW.
>> I IMAGINE, HARRY, THERE'S A
BIG DIVIDE WHEN IT COMES TO AGE?
>> THERE IS A HUGE DIVIDE WHEN
IT COMES TO AGE.
SO IF WE GO TO MY AGE BRACKET,
THE AGE 18 TO 34, 30% SAY THEY
CURRENTLY SMOKE MARIJUANA.
I'M NOT SURE WHERE YOU FIT IN,
I'M NOT GOING TO TRY TO GUESS.
>> I'M 53.
I'M IN THE MIDDLE.
>> YOU'RE IN THE MIDDLE.
>> THE FACT THAT YOU WERE
WONDERING ABOUT IT IS OFFENSIVE.
OKAY, BUT KEEP GOING.
>> KEEP GOING.
WE GO TO MY MOTHER'S AGE
BRACKET, IT'S 7%.
LOOK AT SMOKES CIGARETTES IN THE
LAST WEEK.
THE OPPOSITE AGE PATTERN.
AGE 55 AND OLDER, 14% SAY THEY
SMOKED CIGARETTES IN THE LAST
WEEK.
AGES 34 TO 54, 10%.
IN MY AGE BRACKET, JUST 8%.
MANY MORE PEOPLE IN MY AGE
BRACKET ARE SMOKING MARIJUANA
THAN CIGARETTES.
>> HOW DO AMERICANS FEEL ABOUT
THE IDEA OF LEGALIZING MARIJUANA
TODAY?
>> YEAH, SO AGAIN, THIS GOES
WITH THE TREND THAT WE SAW IN
THE PRIOR SLIDES.
MORE AMERICANS ARE SMOKING
MARIJUANA, AND MORE THAN THAT,
MORE AMERICANS BELIEVE IT SHOULD
BE LEGALIZED.
IN OCTOBER OF 2021, 68%, THE
VAST MAJORITY, SAID THEY BELIEVE
THAT MARIJUANA USE SHOULD BE
LEGAL.
GO BACK TO OCTOBER OF 1969.
IT WAS JUST 12% OF AMERICANS.
AND WE HAVE SEEN THIS STEADY UP
CLIMB.
31% IN SEPTEMBER OF 2000.
AND THEN OCTOBER OF 2011, IT WAS
50/50.
NOW THE CLEAR VAST MAJORITY
BELIEVE MARIJUANA SHOULD BE
LEGAL.
COMPARE THIS TO SOMETHING THAT I
THINK IS INTERESTING ON
CIGARETTE SMOKING.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE
BELIEVE THAT SMOKING CIGARETTES
AT LEAST IN YOUR HOME SHOULD BE
LEGAL, BUT MAKE SMOKING
CIGARETTES ILLEGAL IN PUBLIC
PLACES.
YOU LOOK BACK IN JULY OF 2001,
IT WAS 39%.
YOU LOOK BACK IN JULY OF 2007,
40%.
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN, IN THE
LAST DECADE, WE HAVE CROSSED THE
MAJORITY THRESHOLD.
MOST AMERICANS BELIEVE THAT
SMOKING CIGARETTES SHOULD IN
FACT BE ILLEGAL IN PUBLIC PLACES
AND AT THE SAME TIME, MOST
AMERICANS BELIEVE THAT SMOKING
OR AT LEAST BEING ABLE TO SMOKE
MARIJUANA SOMEWHERE SHOULD BE
LEGAL.
SO VERY DIFFERENTIATING TRENDS
AND THE AGE GAP REAL